there
critical idea that they did
that holds the position
very close in the early nineties
but even at that time
materialistic
there was no such thing as a star
it maintains the consent of people to
defeat of the brain
iran has taken on
the founder of the russian school of
physiology
and make it a great time to
is on the top dog
investigated the functions of the human
brain necklaces
theatrically
this is an unconventional treatment
during his lifetime
man also developed a great provides your
car
that that is meant to be helped
not only the prick of a veto
but even the fact that could lead to
reach
but how about the mentally deranged
does not respond to external british
the organism
these psychic phenomena
were frustrated by threatening to kick
a conflict that might be now
temperature
he made an enormous contribution to this
time
which deals with us
fee and functions of the human brain
pictures
arthritis signs of conviction
competition briefly
especially in treatment of the routines
if you pull them followers
on the top of the fact that you're not
going to do
from the fact that
are continuing the humanistic tradition
of the russian medicine
overlooking the help of
mutation
withholding
to see what the doctor sometime
of greatness
here's what the file
effected by terrifying monsters did
consented to be restored the friendship
and the other patient
care like the wolf
through the bureaucracy
found with the group
propensity not yours
the americans
the breakup here but i don't like it
yet but i think the mid nineteen thirty
while still giving
so how does may post a comment
unexplained
walter ripka
and you'd like to dad
he died from the police
stations image of god
computer
are you a composer to
shostakovich
all across the public is going to get
them out
some of the pockets compositions amount
to
in agreement with him
and of course is associated with the
patient character
exactly
and rejoice in thailand to come
to thirty-two metal
before beginning next week
if they didn't get the story from the
patient himself
means of
restoring the faith
well how do you think
in the hospital
i'm not feeling well
slightly at time
explained to you
they pulled it
three straight
they're not surrounded
everything will be over
thrilled you are your thoughts
talk with her
twelve different countries
late eclipse
tonnage of mother killed itself
the first time they've been living there
and stuff with all the heart of the
blockade
code at the bottom
fewer children
what's your name in china
it was a week for you
easily susceptible to fix
predicting victory movement of
the cuban conscious mind
but that's of course this information
but it won't be probably
relate to the following
do you think it would be anthony m
we're going to get it from work
akal coming remarkable
return
further down the brush to sleep
to push for boris i
down by the card
it is not the only person concerned with
availability
boutrous boutrous imposition
some of the party
hope to identify the continue
depict the organic changes
it is not easy to make it right now
nor is it easy to treat a mental disease
kleenex earlier today
bright
it repeatedly
epileptic secreted
in combination with other remedies
andover ma method
propriety
welcome to the middle of the
they help restoring it
pre-kindergarten
given none of us
critical relatives of the writeup
webster decorative repeated model
description
limitation brusett
as well as hope of recovery
for much importance to me
suspected bernadette
but find the source of the air
to restore the patient goods
and confidence in the cupboard
you know the course of your premises
it is never too
but why should the no
the young woman like you'd be disorder
speed which means i think the court
sometimes
it's the consequence of wrong password
according to reduce the deficit
you'd always be guarded from couple
don't have to pick a date
that's for sure
but we will kill you
figured this out
three point like advantage
film will be after the game
still highly technical intelligence
exclu
thank you counsel
he's got a
now your call
flora fighting strength
for will stay here with this
everything
movie lovers
cheese
power republicans coming here
when you awake
well i will function
twenty four on the road to recovery
yesterday developed with neil tickner
and decided for the treatment of nervous
and mental disorder
its victims of the sliding two to three
eight four individual group reads
they'll colors and another disease
condition
you know a few of the department for
both
and all of the alcoholic beverages
locally organizations alcohol
after weeks of teeth
naman yung iba
looks almost to fifteen seventy
flagging manual
physically
shop to be different
committee meetings
and you've gone through committees
for the treatment of america
videos difficult
the production
but he had to bring to you
presumption however there's not
sufficient ground for a big big
difference jennica corporation
marvin instrument
over the brains electric car
there are electrical phenomena
in the human brain
they were discovered unfettered by
doctor victor
second the old days
where there were no such
great great great here with a completely
afforded the opportunity to prove it
the findings
terms of agnes
an x_-ray of the brain blood vessels
shows the exact location of the cube
now the stations in the private counsel
neurosurgery thirteen thousand decline
that they could use of the few months
will be destroyed by xr
here they gave me
he completed the course of treatment
with wait listed by
and other physical
the physical methods of tragedy to do it
are based on pictage ideas of
never diseases
fresh company convicted
has been found in them
curative method of chinese medicine
treatment by an eagle creek
it's another group ltd
having completed around those dates back
to your logically thank you
we should be put together
productive nineteen
that he should physically rutika
and one more it much
honey champion
came from alcoholic drink
every day to keep up with something
common publicly
political reporting
pr
anxious to be home
the end of another working very in
another city
the underlying the bus
the knowledge that other nations enjoy
higher
russian had nothing to regulate your
mind
think they would like to have
of what should be good
during my summer travels in russia i
found myself
i think that's a cool
they seem to be a general
which is depicted
went out for profit
to explain to me
these two workers are standing in front
psychiatric
this hospital and others like it house
one
for me to countries
moscow had the time
mental care comes
seriously ill get
periodically psychiatric hospital
devoted itself to be careful
clinic such as being tested
you're about to complete give by far the
most
they offer early diagnosis
this is the problem psychiatric dr
real activation
required to wear uniforms
and it will not
beaumont enough process
according to dr betty on
kayakers divers in the patient
at the top of hospital beat the taxes
averaged twenty patients
the most surprising distinctive that
over three-quarters of the doctor
owned by the lady
sorbefacient
in addition to the catch is that there
are three hundred and twenty psychiatric
than the average russian
each nurse takes care of six
a fully qualified man
adequate number two person
tranquilizers
make straitjacket unnecessary
and in fact
we've got a long history of humane
or the bolshevik revolution
i think that every hospital
here the objective
with on bright will blast
this is a reason
thing diagnostic labels
leader they can
lawyering apan
things i do
what it made
conflict with the factory
started thinking
however i assume
theory which dominate russian
emphasize
with this in mind i a journey to the
clinic in moscow
do you know a protracted
here at the clinic
brother in the next
nurtured by sakura
the doctor traditionally begins
with them a nation
for an alcoholic and psychotherapy
inside of it
but not the end
one epileptic
hospital records show that epileptic
makeup eight or nine percent
through the primaries
regarded as a true
twenty five percent
instead of penicillin
still hard to get it
patience with the flu
comprise about
style hospital
according to the russian
the rate of recovery efforts
and sixty one percent of combined
arrivals
these percentages
as you can see that live
button in russia as well
these that your student
defeats the fat
after high school
the medical education in six years
and it's not almost six
in russia the empty
scientific study of entered into force
dr shobha
only twenty five years
she will maintain the
electric sleep rather than
work therapy and supportive therapy go
together
infield refusal
attitudes which is a fascist analyzed by
what faithful
officially president soviet russia as
the capitalism
and then prescribes medical
the basic game intriguing
explore the patient
do not try to get the
to understand
they appear to have it
there's no doubt that
wondering whether or not
training in deficit-cutting would make
for still more effective
the characters who get most facial
but what about the actual
dr castillo you keep children
ward at forty-five
seriously
involving epilepsy
brain damage it
for these emotionally disturbed
mister stephens
here we see a class
at the foreign desk here doctor nephew
fits inside of me to visit her two boys
structure
at the end of each day
it struck me that the
same basic into
that she and others like it
and shown that they
the various hospitals
although they're a bit
widespread in
and
one thing and
they want their prey
to restore the mw
society they live